they're left in the cold
these displaced families in Northern
Syria are facing a new ordeal brought on
by a severe snowstorm
and they're not equipped for the
challenge
as you can see for your own eyes only
this night five tents have collapsed
children left under rain and snow
without any shelter
this situation is the same across all
the displacement camps in aleppo's
Northern Countryside and idlib
low temperatures along with heavy rain
have taken a heavy toll on the people
here most of the tents are not water
resistant there's a visible absence of
essential sanitary facilities
foul water ponds fill the streets and
surround the tents thick mud restricts
movement and makes it difficult to
deliver clean drinking water to the
camps children in particular are
suffering the most
all the children in the camp are sick if
we want to take a child to a hospital we
have no alternative but to carry it
through the mud and walk a long distance
to the main road mud and water are
everywhere we are left without anything
to keep us warm
serious humanitarian response
coordinators are warning of a further
deterioration of the situation in the
camps more snowfall is predicted in the
coming days
and they are calling on International
relief agencies for help
in addition to food and clothes there is
a desperate need for heating equipment
and there are warnings of possible
deaths because of the severe cold
there are nearly 2 million displaced
people in Northern Syria living in camps
along the Turkish border and many of
them need urgent help to get them
through a tough winter Muhammad Al
Jazeera